you got kids yeah i got three how old
are your kids uh
18 19 and then 28.
god do they come on the road with you my
son opens for me every now and then the
no the the 19 year old he wants and he
what kind of he don't want to do it he
just has it
he don't want to do it he'll just go and
be like yeah i'm gonna go up tonight
and no and we'll wing it and crush
i'm like this kid he's got the game
oh he just talks about being mixed and
do you do you post them
yeah there's one on youtube they're his
first set ever is on youtube
but do you post them on instagram ever
no i don't see you much on
like i don't see you posting he doesn't
like me posting them
he's an odd kid he's like nah dad don't
post me
18 19 and 28. is it austin or
austin what's the 28 year old up to uh
he's in ohio live with his girlfriend
just working
all right just doing this thing this is
do you remember
gary the first joke you ever told on
stage
i'm always curious son yeah gary's on
austin do you wanna watch it all right
chill i don't know it's weird when i
watch myself start
sweating because there's pressures on
them to laugh
well you'll see my [ __ ] sons
that's so funny where is this tommy t is
where i'm at this weekend
before covet this was two years ago and
did he have a plan before he went out
this is like one o'clock because i'm
gonna go up tonight and this is like
eight o'clock but the huevos on this kid
but look at he's like wait wait do you
see his stage friends oh he's like this
what's up
i can't imagine doing that i'm nervous
yeah i am too i'm nervous for it
he was being cocky goes dad i can do
that i said do it
he decided while you were there yeah
yeah yeah is he in school or
at the house right here oh this is two
years ago he's 17. i can't believe how
old your kids
feel like we're all the same
this is my first time doing stand up so
even if i'm not funny please laugh at my
jokes
currently i'm uh i'm a 17.
i currently live in the state of ohio
but we're
moving out here uh this summer i'm gonna
be going
to uh the high school called heritage i
heard a lot i've heard a lot of good
things about it
yeah he starts getting into jokes
that's the only thing i told him to do
get the crowd on your side hype up the
warriors yep
holy [ __ ] there's so many
also i don't know what i want to do
after school i kind of want to sit home
and do nothing and play video games
so if there's any sugar mamas or cougars
out there
look at gary he's all like madness on
the stage right now
dude he's great yeah
he's got a real solid joke right here
it's
[Music]
this is a strong bit right here
like his ancestors
judy crushed it those are two great
shows sweating he crushed it
you're gone
you can stop it dude that was good it
was impressive yeah
i'm sweating i was sweating that's
awesome but he was so he looked so calm
yeah that's just his demeanor he's got
the gift i mean he but he doesn't want
to do it what do you want to do who
knows
is he just chilling at home though yeah
that's my biggest fear i'm like this
he's just chilling right now
but we also put a lot of i think in
society we say once you graduate high
school you've got to figure out what you
want to do yeah for sure i'm okay with
doing the break year i'd be like let's
just figure it out like what's your
passion
what do you want because he's not a he
doesn't want to go to college my
daughter's in college
that's the route she wants to take i'm
cool with it but he i know i always knew
girl but but
i think certain kids are meant for
college but then also when i think back
on college when you
get your freshman year and like all
right what are you what's your major
like [ __ ]
i don't know right yeah titties what do
you want me to do i i can decide right
now what i'm gonna do for the next four
years
my youngest son didn't go to college he
came back and he was just like yeah
that's not for me
and i i was like fine fine man and he's
doing he's doing great but
schools do that they they need to put
the stress uh chase your passion
not trace education chase education yeah
chase your passion whatever that is
right when i get off stage at the lap
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song